Trascrizione: Chiara Bartolozzi
Revisore: Veronica Viscardi
(Applausi)
Buonasera a tutti,
io sono Elena Di Giovanni.
Sono professoressa associata
all'Università di Macerata.
Mi occupo soprattutto di accessibilità,
accessibilità ai media e allo spettacolo,
in particolare, al teatro e ai musei.
Quindi diciamo,
in senso lato, alla cultura.
Stasera sono qua nella duplice veste
di ricercatrice e di sperimentatrice.
Questo perché sin dall’inizio
della mia attività nell’accessibilità,
ho voluto mettere le mani in pasta.
Volevo fare qualcosa
che mi permettesse di applicarla.
Poi sono passata in qualche modo
dall’accessibilità all’inclusione.
Ma questo lo vedremo tra poco.
Come sempre si fa negli eventi
ormai dedicati all’inclusione,
mi presento anche a livello fisico.
Potrebbe esserci qualcuno che non vede,
o che non vede bene dalla sua posizione.
Sono una donna di 50 anni.
Ho un viso piuttosto
allungato, abbronzato.
Sono abbastanza magra.
Indosso un maglioncino nero,
un pantalone nero largo.
E oggi ho i capelli raccolti.
Aggiungo che tendo a gesticolare molto.
Detto questo,
entriamo nel vivo
della nostra chiacchierata,
che sarà appunto imperniata
su cinque parole chiave.
Sono quelle del titolo.
Le prime due sono più importanti.
Accessibilità e inclusione.
Parto però facendo
un piccolo passo indietro.
O meglio, un piccolo excursus storico.
Parlerò di quelli che per me
sono tre pilastri,
per vedere quello che è successo
nel mondo in cui viviamo
in termini di accessibilità
e di inclusione.
Il primo pilastro è la Dichiarazione
Universale dei Diritti Umani.
È stata approvata grazie
al lavoro delle Nazioni Unite,
portato avanti subito dopo
la Seconda Guerra Mondiale, nel 1948.
Ad oggi, la Dichiarazione
Universale dei Diritti Umani
è stata tradotta in 500 lingue.
Forse anche di più.
È alla base delle leggi nazionali
e internazionali sui diritti umani.
Per quello che interessa noi oggi,
due sono i pilastri fondamentali
di questa Dichiarazione.
Sono il diritto alla pari dignità
e il diritto all’accesso.
Per diritto all’accesso si intende
accesso all’informazione,
accesso ai servizi sanitari,
accesso anche all’intrattenimento.
Quindi al mondo dello spettacolo
e della cultura,
che sono quelli ai quali
farò riferimento di più.
Il secondo pilastro è in alto
nella nostra slide.
È la Convenzione dei Diritti
di Persone con Disabilità.
È un documento più recente,
sempre promosso
dalle Nazioni Unite nel 2006,
ratificato dall’Italia nel 2019.
Ad oggi sono, se non erro,
182 i Paesi che lo hanno ratificato.
È un documento importante.
Per quanto mi riguarda, forse,
l’elemento più interessante
è che al centro del documento
non c’è la disabilità come mancanza.
C’è l’essere umano con tutte
le sue diverse capacità, abilità.
E il diritto all’uguaglianza.
Da qui, torniamo al concetto
di accessibilità e di inclusione.
Il terzo pilastro è un po’ diverso,
non è un documento.
È in realtà non l’Organizzazione
Mondiale della Sanità,
ma la sua definizione di disabilità,
che si trova, per esempio,
sul sito dell’organizzazione.
Secondo me è una definizione
molto interessante,
perché riporta la disabilità
in una sfera molto più globale,
che ci vede di nuovo tutti protagonisti.
Si parla infatti di disabilità
temporanea o permanente.
E secondo l’Organizzazione
Mondiale della Sanità,
la disabilità temporanea
e quella permanente
meritano la stessa attenzione.
Per disabilità temporanea,
spesso quando parlo di inclusione,
faccio un esempio, che è
un esempio che mi riguarda.
Racconto questo ai miei studenti.
Circa dieci anni fa,
sono stata in Giappone.
Io lavoro con l'inglese.
Sono convinta che la lingua inglese
apra le porte di tutto il mondo.
In realtà mi trovo in Giappone
e mi rendo conto
che è quasi impossibile comunicare.
Perché continuo a tentare di fare domande,
o di interagire in inglese,
e mi ritrovo continuamente
persone che chinano il capo.
Allora all’inizio il mio pensiero era:
“Stanno dicendo di sì”.
Poi ho capito che in realtà
non c’era una comunicazione.
E non è stato semplice,
perché io ho delle difficoltà.
Ci sono cose che non mangio.
Non sapevo mai quello
che avrei avuto nel piatto.
E perché avevo il desiderio
di comprare ad esempio dei DVD.
Sono tornata in Italia senza DVD.
Quindi quella, nella sua banalità,
era una situazione di disabilità.
Una disabilità linguistica,
ma comunque invalidante.
Per l’Organizzazione Mondiale della Sanità
la disabilità deve essere trattata
in questo modo.
In modo da garantire a tutti
in particolare una sanità,
che sia accessibile e inclusiva.
E da qui passiamo
alle due parole centrali di oggi,
che sono accessibilità e inclusione.
Io ve le presento così.
Ci ho ragionato io, in qualche modo
in termini pratici.
Cioè, forse non ci ho
nemmeno ragionato, a priori.
Ci sono arrivata naturalmente,
conducendo una serie di progetti
di cui vi parlerò.
Alcuni ve li illustrerò.
Sono legati alla disabilità sensoriale.
Quindi persone cieche, ipovedenti,
sorde e ipoudenti.
L’accessibilità per me
è dare alle persone con abilità diverse
la possibilità di accedere a luoghi,
servizi ed eventi
che altrimenti non sarebbero accessibili.
In termini metaforici,
l’accessibilità parte da -1,
una condizione negativa,
e vuole arrivare ad una posizione
per quanto possibile neutrale.
Quindi a uno 0.
L’inclusione invece parte
da una posizione 0 di neutralità.
Per me l’inclusione significa
concepire, progettare e realizzare
eventi, luoghi e spettacoli fruibili
da quante più persone possibili.
E che queste persone
con diverse abilità siano coinvolte
in ogni fase della creazione
di un progetto o evento inclusivo.
Quindi, dalla creazione,
alla realizzazione, alla fruizione.
Appunto, quindi l’inclusione ci porta
da uno 0 in realtà ad un +1.
Ovvero, ci porta a costruire
o aggiungere qualcosa alla nostra vita
e anche in generale alla società.
Per rafforzare un po’ questa
mia naturale evoluzione verso l’inclusione
di solito mi appoggio a questo testo.
Mi ci sono molto trovata.
Il testo si chiama:
“The Universal Access Handbook”.
È un testo di Stephanidis
nel quale l’autore dice:
"Agli albori del 2020",
è stato scritto pochi anni fa,
“l’accessibilità non basta più,
non è più sufficiente”.
E segna, Stephanidis,
la differenza fra l’accessibilità
e l’inclusione,
parlando di un approccio
reattivo da una parte,
e di un approccio proattivo dall’altra.
Ciò non vuol dire che l’accessibilità
non ci va più bene, anzi.
L’accessibilità ci permette ad esempio
di intervenire sull’esistente.
Noi vogliamo rendere accessibile
a più persone possibili
l’anfiteatro romano di Urbisaglia?
Bene, non possiamo rifarlo.
Dobbiamo intervenire sull’esistente.
Intervenendo sull’esistente,
in questo caso come in tanti altri,
in qualche modo si stimola
un ripensamento della fruizione,
e anche dell’usabilità
di tutta una serie di cose.
A partire da un luogo come questo.
E un merito dell’accessibilità
è stato quello, nel tempo,
anche di creare consapevolezza.
La consapevolezza delle esigenze
di tante persone diverse.
L’inclusione invece prevede
un approccio proattivo.
Innanzitutto secondo me,
e secondo anche Stephanidis,
l’inclusione è un modo di pensare.
E non è mai un obiettivo finale.
È un processo in divenire.
Questo perché l’inclusione
nasce, idealmente,
come un qualcosa che davvero,
anche a livello progettuale,
comprende tutti con le nostre esigenze.
Ma non è sempre possibile
comprendere tutti.
In un progetto inclusivo
si può partire da qui.
Dedicandosi ad alcune persone,
ad alcune categorie.
E poi si può sempre comunque
aggiungere qualcosa.
Una cosa molto importante per me.
Non parliamo di inclusione
in termini di disabilità,
ma in termini di diversità,
quindi di diverse abilità.
Non è un termine negativo
quello che usiamo,
ma un termine positivo.
Ecco un’altra parola chiave
del mio titolo.
L’inclusione prevede
la partecipazione di tutti,
di quante più persone possibili.
E la partecipazione è ciò che molto spesso
poi determina e stimola la soddisfazione.
La soddisfazione di tutti, di chi
guida e partecipa al progetto,
di chi assiste e di chi impara.
Ora vi parlo di alcuni dei progetti
che ho seguito direttamente.
Alcuni sono progetti del cuore.
Parliamo prima di quelli di accessibilità.
Vedete nell’immagine in alto,
una ragazza sorda
che sta usando la lingua dei segni.
Sta usando la lingua
dei segni per raccontare
ad un gruppo di persone
sorde segnanti come lei
la “Carmen” di Bizet.
Uno spettacolo andato in scena
in un teatro della Lombardia
in una modalità standard,
cantato peraltro in francese.
Che cosa succede per la persona sorda?
Intanto può seguire i sottotitoli,
in questo caso erano in italiano.
E poi, non tutti i sordi riescono
a leggere a grande velocità.
Prima dello spettacolo, un percorso
guidato in lingua dei segni
illustra gli elementi importanti.
Per esempio, i climax della musica
o l’enfasi del cantato.
Ciò rende lo spettacolo accessibile.
A destra, vedete due bambini sordi
che stanno toccando un tamburo.
Questo sempre prima di uno spettacolo.
Qui forse avrete riconosciuto
lo Sferisterio di Macerata.
I due bambini sordi vanno a toccare
il tamburo per percepire le onde
che emana il tamburo durante il suono.
Il sordo non percepisce il suono
in forma di audio,
ma lo percepisce proprio in forma di onda.
Questo è un modo
per far conoscere al bambino sordo
come nasce e si propaga la musica.
Sulla sinistra vedete due persone,
in questo caso credo fossero russi,
che stanno assistendo
a uno spettacolo in italiano.
Attraverso un’app
possono seguire lo spettacolo
anche con una traduzione
nella loro lingua.
E infine, in basso vedete le mani
di due persone cieche.
Il cieco utilizza molto il tatto
come senso, questo è ovvio.
Il tatto aiuta a compensare
la mancanza della vista.
In questo caso, stanno toccando
una mappa tattile.
La mappa tattile riproduce
la struttura del teatro.
In questo caso, lo Sferisterio.
Potrebbe essere l’anfiteatro
dove ci troviamo ora.
Per un cieco, comprendere
come è suddiviso e organizzato lo spazio
prima di entrare in quello spazio,
è un grande aiuto.
Passiamo all’inclusione.
Per l’inclusione,
ho messo i progetti del cuore.
Alcuni dei progetti.
Allora intanto, in alto a destra
e in basso a sinistra,
vedete due ragazzini ipovedenti.
Quello in alto credo abbia sui 7 anni,
quello in basso ne ha 14.
In questo caso, da diversi anni
io e il mio team
mettiamo in campo
tutta una serie di attività,
per rendere gli spettacoli
per ragazzi realmente inclusivi.
Cosa serve a un ragazzino cieco
per partecipare?
In questo caso era un “Rigoletto”
adattato ai bambini.
Quindi già una versione proprio
per avvicinare l’opera al bambino.
Per il cieco non basta,
o comunque anche l’ipovedente.
Noi facciamo dei laboratori
all’interno dei quali questi ragazzi
riescono a realizzare degli elementi
che porteranno durante lo spettacolo.
In questo caso, un bastone della pioggia,
che poi i bambini agitano
insieme ad altri bambini
che partecipano con lo stesso strumento
durante lo spettacolo.
In basso il ragazzo
sta registrando la sua voce.
Per un cieco, uno spettacolo non è
accessibile dal punto di vista visivo.
Quindi serve una descrizione.
In questo caso, noi creiamo
delle descrizioni.
Dei personaggi, dei costumi,
delle scenografie, del trucco,
proprio insieme ai ragazzi,
negoziando ogni singola parola.
Poi registriamo queste descrizioni
con le loro voci.
I ragazzi ciechi sono
bravissimi a memorizzare.
E durante lo spettacolo,
loro insieme alle loro famiglie
possono ascoltare la descrizione
che accompagna lo spettacolo
con le loro voci.
In basso, un altro progetto del cuore.
È un progetto recente.
Abbiamo organizzato un corso
per guide inclusive.
Sono ragazzi, quelli che vedete
con il diploma.
Sordi e ciechi, ipovedenti e ipoudenti.
Tra i 13 e i 25 anni.
Sono ragazzi che hanno fatto con noi
all’interno di un museo
un percorso di formazione
per diventare guide,
per poi portare con il loro linguaggio
tutti quanti, gruppi
il più possibile misti, eterogenei,
quindi bambini con disabilità,
anziani, genitori e altro,
a fare una visita al museo
esplorandolo con il loro linguaggio.
Torno a un framework un po’ generale.
Dopo la pratica si torna
sempre alla riflessione.
Soprattutto con un lavoro come il mio.
Ecco una delle teorie
che mi è stata finora più d’aiuto.
Il design inclusivo.
Non è esattamente come quella
del design universale, più nota.
Questa teoria mette al centro
la qualità della vita delle persone
di tutte le età e di tutte le abilità.
I principi del design inclusivo
sono quelli che vediamo.
Ovvero, le persone in primis.
La diversità, di cui abbiamo già parlato.
Quindi le diverse caratteristiche, tutte.
La scelta,
ovvero la possibilità
di andare in un museo
e non avere solo un percorso obbligato,
e magari un pochino ghettizzante,
se si ha una disabilità.
Ma poter scegliere come fruire
di spazi culturali e spettacoli.
La flessibilità.
Flessibilità nell’uso.
Flessibilità nella fruizione
di uno spettacolo.
E infine la comodità.
Ovvero la sensazione, con diverse abilità,
di non essere diverso.
Ma di poter godere comodamente,
come tutti gli altri,
di uno spettacolo, di un museo,
di un evento.
Infine, il design inclusivo,
secondo me valorizza quindi la diversità.
La considera non soltanto
in termini neutrali,
ma la considera una ricchezza,
e vi garantisco che è così.
Lavorando con le disabilità sensoriali
e soprattutto con i bambini,
ci si arricchisce moltissimo
a livello umano e affettivo,
ma anche di conoscenza.
Si impara a vedere il mondo diversamente.
Il design inclusivo inoltre prevede
la condivisione, la partecipazione,
in tutte le fasi possibili.
È quindi uno strumento
per il cambiamento sociale.
L’inclusione più ci rende
tutti protagonisti,
più ci valorizza, più ci porta
a cambiare la società.
Per inciso quella nella foto sono io
con una bambina cieca,
prima di un spettacolo.
Giochiamo con un tessuto che poi
sarà presente nello spettacolo.
Infine, il design inclusivo
è uno strumento che vuole aumentare,
far crescere il benessere
collettivo e individuale.
E proprio il benessere è l’ultimo elemento
su cui vorrei riflettere.
Ed è anche l’elemento su cui
stiamo lavorando con alcune colleghe.
Siamo passati dall’accessibilità
all’inclusione.
Dall’inclusione,
alla voglia di comprendere quanto
l’inclusione faccia bene alle persone.
L’impatto sulla loro felicità
e la loro soddisfazione.
Qui vedete due disegni.
Due disegni realizzati
da bambini sordi e ciechi.
In particolare, il collage l'ha fatto
una bambina ipovedente.
Ha voluto inserire dei colori.
Il suo ricordo dello spettacolo
è a colori.
Un altro strumento che utilizziamo
con i bambini lo vedete in alto.
Una scala con gli smileys che misura
la loro felicità e soddisfazione,
e quindi la crescita del loro benessere.
E con questo io vi lascio.
Spero che la chiacchierata
sia stata utile,
e che i progetti inclusivi
possano sempre crescere ovunque.
Grazie.
(Applausi)